Raymond bar à l'Assemblée économie
rigueur et vigueur social dialogue et
concertation politique union et
cohabitation le débat continue il y aura
un vote demain Italie les recherches du
corps d'Aldo Moro sans résultat le
président giscardestin au Conseil des
ministres la France réprouve la barbarie
Cambodge 78 21h30 question de temps
Antenne 2 présente le premier film
tourné chez lesmer
rouges mesdames messieurs bonsoir Comme
prévu donc crémonar a engagé la
responsabilité de son gouvernement dans
le débat qui s'est ouvert cet après-midi
à l'Assemblée nationale le débat de
politique générale du 3e gouvernement
par nous essaierons d'être le plus
complet le plus synthétique possible sur
les principales mesures économiques et
sociales annoncées par le Premier
ministre nous détaillerons l'annonce de
l'étude d'un prélèvement sur les grosses
fortunes un retour progressif à la
liberté des prix l'augmentation des
tarifs publics le plafonnement des
différents impôts au taux actuels pour 2
ans les mesur en faveur de l'épargne
l'augmentation du SMIC plus rapide que
la moyenne des salaires l'instauration
d'un revenu familial minimum pour les
familles nombreuses l'année prochaine et
cetera et cetera mais d'abord la
philosophie de ces mesures le
redressement n'est pas fini à diremontb
il faut le continuer dans l'effort et la
rigueur pour faire face au profond
changements qui se sont produit au cours
des dernières années dans le monde il
n'est pas pour nous d'autres lois que la
loi de
l'effort que personne ne s'y
trompe que personne ne s'y trompe nous
avons pu dans des circonstances
difficiles arrêter les évolutions très
préoccupantes qui se manifestaient dans
notre économie à la fin de l'été
1976 nous avons pu amorcer le
redressement économique et financier du
pays en évitant la récession et
l'amputation du pouvoir d'achat des
Français ce qui ne s'est pas produit
dans d'autres pays mais la tâche qui
reste à accomplir est encore
considérable nous avons non seulement à
éliminer le virus inflationniste qui
mine notre économie mais nous avons
surtout à adapter la France aux
nouvelles conditions de l'économie
internationale bien alors essayons
d'analyser tout cela dans le détail
Philippe Sassier avec d'abord ces trois
grands objectifs pour 1980 le premier
rétablir les grands équilibres
c'està-dire les prix le commerce
extérieur et la monnaie le second
renforcer notre appareil de production
c'est-à-dire donner du muscle aux
entreprises françaises les rendre plus
compétitive le 3oème mener une politique
vigoureuse d'aménagement du territoire
c'est-à-dire resserrer le tissu
industriel français et créer des
activités nouvelles là où il y a des
emplois qui sont menacés pour parvenir à
cette rigueur et pour atteindre ces
objectifs le Premier ministre a défini
quatre grands principes d'abord
maintenir un franc solide deuxièmement
modérer la progression de la masse
monétaire cela signifie en particulier
bien regarder ce que devient le crédit
et le contrôler troisièmement limiter le
déficit budgétaire oui à un déficite
budgétaire pour aider l'activité
économique mais pas en le il ne faut pas
le financer par la planche à Billé
c'est-à-dire par l'inflation enfin le
pouvoir d'achat des Français sera
maintenu mais la hausse des salaires
sera ralenti alors voilà pour le cadre
général rentrons dans le détail d'un
discours qui est d'abord celui d'un
économiste et parmi tous les thèmes
abordés l'énergie l'Europe la France
rurale la protection de la mer il y a ce
désir constant d'assaainir les
structures économiques et notamment de
restructurer l'industrie s'il fallait
schématiser un peu trivialement je
dirais pas de pitié pour les
canardbouetteux des branches
industrielles importantes la précédente
assemblée avait été saisie de certains
problèmes doivent retrouver des
structures concurrentielles pour assurer
leur avenir des entreprises en
difficulté doivent saisir des chances
nouvelles en se réorganisant et en
renouvelant le cas échéant leur
dirigeants les moyens
considérables consacrés à maintenir en
vie des installations industrielles sans
avenir les moyens
considérables consacrés à maintenir en
vie des installations industrielles sans
avenir seront mieux utilisés à stimuler
les sorts d'activités nouvelles CAPA
d'offrir des emplois plus sûrs et plus
durables l'intérêt de nos travailleurs
et de nos régions n'est pas de prolonger
à n'importe quel prix le passé mais de
construire l'avenir alors au travers de
tout cela de projet net c'est un projet
libéral il faut aider au maximum les
entreprises oui la restructuration
industrielle repose sur une idée
fondamentale l'État ne peut pas ne peut
plus tout faire il faut rendre leur
responsabilité aux entreprises pour
réussir ce projet libéral le Premier
ministre a défini quatre grands axes
d'action la fiscalité l'impôt sur les
sociétés sur les revenus les charges
sociales et la TVA n'augmenteront pas
cette année ni en 1979 cela avait déjà
été annoncé à Blois dans le programme
deuxièmement l'épargne il y aura des
mesures en faveur des actions
c'est-à-dire des boursiers deuxièmement
on va favoriser par une hausse d'intérêt
hausse des taux d'intérêt l'épargne à
long terme c'est-à-dire celle qui
accepte de s'investir d'aller quelque
part et non pas simplement d'attendre
dans sur un compte chèque ou bien dans
une caisse d'épargne des mesures
également en faveur de la trésorerie et
plus particulièrement des fonds propres
des entreprises afin qu'elles puissent
investir mieux troisièmement les prix
retour progressif mais irréversible à la
liberté des prix industriels une
nouvelle loi devrait remplacer
l'ordonnance de 1945 pour les
entreprises publiques qui ont coûté
environ 30 milliards de francs à l'état
l'an passé le la règle sera vérité des
prix c'est-à-dire un calcul plus juste
du ticket de métro du billet de train ou
bien de la quittance d'électricité mais
unee augmentation si il y aura des
augmentations mais alors attention le
Premier ministre a bien précisé liberté
et retour à donc à cette liberté la
vérité ne veut pas dire l'axisme
c'est-à-dire ne doit pas se faire sur le
dos du consommateur enfin 4è grand axe
les petites et les moyennes entreprises
l'agriculture et les artisans pouront
faire l'objet d'une attention
particulière ce qui a aussi frappé la
plupart des observateurs c'est la
recherche par le Premier ministre d'un
véritable dialogue social et d'une
concertation permanente avec les
syndicats et là on n pas retrouvé le
même mbarde il y a un an et
demi la politique sociale que le
gouvernement entend conduire s'inspirera
d'une double volonté pratiquer une large
concertation avec les organisation
professionnelles et
syndicales favoriser les négociations
sur certaines questions qui intéressent
plus directement les partenaires sociaux
et qui engagent leur
responsabilité
ce dialogue doit tenir compte des rôles
respectifs et des responsabilités
différentes des partenaires sociaux et
de l'état estil en outre besoin de
rappeler qu'une politique sociale
efficass ne consiste pas à distribuer
plus que ce que l'on produit et à
compromettre par des générosités à court
terme un progrès social véritable et
durable alors apparment on n plus en
septembre 76 va beaucoup discuter
beaucoup se concerter oui en politique
sociale une grande loi augmenter les
revenus les plus défavorisés augmenter
les revenus des familles les plus
modestes et améliorer les conditions du
travail manuel et là c'est la
concertation qui doit jouer le plus
possible entre les différents
partenaires sociaux c'est d' un
véritable projet de renégociation de
solidarité nationale que lance le
premier ministre les rémunérations le
SMIC va progresser doit progresser plus
vite que la moyenne des salaires sera
relevé le 1er mai le 1er juillet et le
1er décembre de cette année syndicats et
organisation professionnelles
discuteront ensemble pour fixer branche
par branche un minimum réel de
rémunération qui sera garanti l'an
prochain sera institué un revenu
familial minimum pour une famille de
trois enfants l'emploi l'emploi des
jeunes reste la priorité certaines
mesures du Pacte national de l'emploi de
l'année dernière vont être reconduites
des exonérations fiscales seront
étudiées pour les petites et les
moyennes entreprises qui embaucheront
embaucheront notamment des jeunes et
enfin on va rechercher le moyen de
développer le travail à temps partiel la
fiscalité renforcement de la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale mise à l'étude
d'un prélèvement sur les grosses
fortunes et suppression d'avantages
fiscaux qui bénéficient au gros revenus
concertation les syndicats seront
informés des perspectives d'évolution
des différentes branches industrielles
et des décisions de la politique
industrielle les négociations concernant
les conventions Collectiv seront
amélioré dans leur procédure et enfin la
participation va recevoir une nouvelle
impulsion aussi bien dans les
entreprises que sur le plan local voilà
donc pour l'aspect économique et social
des choses et il est vrai que de très
loin c'est le plus importantad dire
Monbar n'en a pas pour autant oublié la
politique pure avec d'entré de jeu au
début de son discours un appel à l'unité
des partis de la majorité pour aider le
gouvernement dans son
action dans l'action qu'il va conduire
le gouvernement entend établir une
étroite collaboration avec l'Assemblée
nationale il compte sur les formations
de la majorité pour soutenir résolument
et pour contrôler positivement cette
action puis-je leur demander plus
particulièrement de maintenir entre
elles pendant cette législature l'esprit
de loyauté réciproque et d'unité dont
elles ont fait preuve pendant la période
électorale et qui a été le principal
facteur de leur
succès leurs électeurs ne comprendraient
pas que des tensions et des querelles
compromettent les chances que donneent
au pays l'existence d'une majorité large
et
cohérente le gouvernement pour sa part
entend agir avec sa majorité non pas
contre elle non pas sans elle il n'aura
pas d'autre souci je vous en donne
l'assurance
que de préserver et de fortifier
l'entente majoritaire alors après rart
tous les groupes de l'Assemblée devrait
intervenir un à un mais avant d'écouter
l'intervention de leur leader une touche
d'ambiance avec Daniel Brem alors
comment ce discours a été perçu dans les
couloirs Daniel et bien toutes les
réflexions convergent les élections ont
eu un effet calmant l'atmosphère était à
la décrispation et presque du côté de
l'opposition à la cohabitation
raisonnable mais j'ai noté que Claude
Labé le président du groupe RP n'a
trouvé aucun point noir et rien qui le
choque dans ce discours que Monsieur
Bolot du même groupe l'a trouvé très
très très apaisant ce qui signifie un
vote massif du RPR ce n'était pas le cas
souvenez-vous il y a un an à l'UDF
messsieurs Bariani et Chartier l'ont
trouvé solide une bonne base de travail
à enrichir un ponton où on peut arrimer
des choses enfin en revanche pour
Monsieur chandnagor socialiste qui trop
embrasse Malé trin ce n'est pas parce
que Monsieur bar a du temps devant lui
qu'il ne doit pas faire dresser un
calendrier précis pour réaliser les
mesures enfin Monsieur fitterman chez
les communistes ce n'est évidemment pas
le remède qu'il faut au mal les
communistes sont opposés à ce programme
mais cela étant s'il y a des textes
intéressant ils ne refuseront pas de les
voter merci Daniel voilà donc pour les
tribunes maintenant pour les couloirs
pardon maintenant la tribune écoutons
donc les quatre porte-paroles des
groupes parlementaires tour à tour les
députés au complet ont pu entendre
Michel DEBRE pour le RPR François
mitteran pour le Parti socialiste Robert
Ballanger pour le PC et Roger Chinot
pour l'UDF alors je vous laisse écouter
un extrait de leurs
interventions d'abord Michel
Debray mes chers collègues nous avons
voulu devant l'électeur notre
solidarité nous avons invité électeurs
et électrices à mélanger leurs bulletins
que personne ne cherche d'autres
combinaisons on peut certes imaginer de
graves circonstances qui imposant un
consentement plus large même pour un
salut public une véritable union
nationale mais vouloir par des astuces
secondaires altérer l'expression du
suffrage et chercher à diviser la
majorité sur
l'essentiel ce serait en son début
condamner cette législature à
l'impuissance mais la situation
politique elle a-t-elle changé
assurément les élections législatives
étai devant vous et vous étiez perdu
elles sont derrière nous et vous êtes
sauvé
enfin
sauver sauver des autres et par les
autres et non point sauvé par vous-même
ni surtout sauvé de
vous-même quoi qu'il en
soit quoi qu'il en
soit quoi qu'il en soit peuple français
sait
prononcé sa décision s'impose à nous
vous ne pouvez désormais rejeter la
responsabilité du pays sur quiconque
vous avez les moyens d'agir si votre
majorité vous les donne vous en avez le
temps si l'événement le permet la gauche
n'ayant pas su dominer ses
contradictions laisse à la droite le
soin de gouverner avec les sienes quant
à la majorité elle se retrouve avec
l'adhésion d'à peine la moitié des
Français divisé en deux groupes
rivaux divisé en deux groupes
Rivau le moins nombreux étant celui qui
se réclame directement du président de
la
République
l'unité elle passe par le respect des
autres nous rechercherons en ce qui nous
concerne le dialogue loyal plus digne
que la stérilité des affrontements
systématique quel qu'il
soit libéraux
évolutionnistes nous souhaitons être
avec d'autres des acteurs créatifs de
plus d'unité
française nous souhaitons contribuer à
mettre fin au manichisme dégradant de
deux moitié de Français qui
s'affronteraient sur tout et je ne vois
d'ailleurs pas
pouroi mem de la majorité nous ne
choisirions pas cette voie dès lors que
nous avons confiance en nous-même en
notre volonté
d'action divisé en deux groupes
rivaux le moins nombreux étant celui qui
se réclame directement du président de
la
République l'unité
elle passe par le des autres nous
rechercherons en ce qui nous concerne le
dialogue loyal plus digne que la
stérilité des affrontements
systématiques quel qu'il
soit libéraux
évolutionnistes nous souhaitons être
avec d'autres des acteurs créatifs de
plus d'unité
française nous souhaitons contribuer à
mettre fin au manicisme dégradant de
deux moitié de Français qui
s'affronteraient sur tout et je ne vois
d'ailleurs pas pourquoi
membres de la majorité nous ne
choisirions pas cette voie dès lors que
nous avons confiance en nous-mêmes en
notre volonté d'action et que nous
sommes d'ailleurs dépositaires de la
confiance de la majorité du corps
électoral ce refus de la démocratie et
du changement nous venons de le
retrouveré dans l'intervention de
Monsieur le Premier Ministre si certains
pouvaient encore avoir des illusions
elles doivent tomber il en est de
l'ouverture sociale comme de l'ouverture
politique la contradiction est flagrante
entre le discours et les actes le trè
gouvernement de monsur bar c'est à
l'évidence la continuité dans le REF
opposé revendication pourant si légitime
des travailleurs la continuité dansérité
qui enfance toujours un peu plus la
France dans la crise le ton nous diton a
changé mais ce n'est pas un changement
de ton don nous avons besoin monsieur
c'est un changement de
politique puis il y a quelques minutes
Jean Royer au nom des 15 nonincrits de
l'Assemblée monté à son tour à la
tribune vous pu entendre l'ensemble de
tout ce débat en direct cet après-midi
sur Antenne 2 alors prenons un petit peu
le temps du recul Noël Copin qu'est-ce
qu'il restera de cette soirée et de
cette journée au Parlement d'abord pas
de suspens au vote de demain non à vrai
dire depuis quelques jours depuis que
l'on sait que Monsieur Michel DEBRE qui
est aujourd'hui le porte-parole du
groupe RPR s'apprêtait à annoncé que le
groupe RPR voterait la confiance au
gouvernement il n'y avait plus de
suspense alors c'est peut-être ce qui
est le plus intéressant justement
l'attitude de la majorité dans dans son
ensemble politiquement oui politiquement
donc la majorité quasi unanime va voter
la confiance au gouvernement mais il est
important quand même de rappeler que
pour Monsieur Debray en substance la
confiance est aussi une affaire de
réciprocité et que si la majorité
s'apprête à à suivre le gouvernement il
faut aussi que le gouvernement lui ne
songe pas à changer de majorité le
Premier ministre avait déjà répondu à
l'avance à Monsieur Debray en parlant
lui-même de l'union de la majorité mais
pour lui on le sait dans l'esprit
d'ailleurs de la 5e République cette
unité de la majorité se fait sur une
politique une politique qui a redéfini
aujourd'hui à partir des grandes
orientations du président de la
République leressement économique la
lutte contre les inégalités et puis la
responsabilité des citoyens et à ce
propos d'ailleurs monsieur bar a
consacré une partie de son discours à ce
que l'on appelle la démocratie locale et
il an un certain nombre d'initiatives
concernant les collectivités locales et
la fiscalité locale alors voilà donc
pour la majorité maintenant pour
l'opposition on ne semble pas prêt à
croire beaucoup en cette ouverture
annoncé par non quelques petites nuances
dans les discours de Monsieur mitteran
et de Monsieur Balanger monsieur
Balanger se réfère explicitement au
programme commun à l'union de la gauche
monsieur miteran lui n'a pas fait ses
références et s'est contenté comme on
l'a entendu d'ironiser sur le fait que
la majorité a été sauvée par les
contradictions de la gauche mais l'un et
l'autre se retrouvent finalement dans le
refus deou ouverture ou plus exactement
il ne croit pas à l'ouverture sociale il
ne croit pas à l'ouverture politique
cependant on sent bien que pour l'un
comme pour l'autre il s'agit de jouer
son rôle sur le plan parlementaire je
crois que c'est peut-être la conclusion
que l'on peut tirer de cette première
journée sans que ce soit une conclusion
quand même trop hative c'est que chacun
est prêt à jouer son rôle il y a une
majorité et il y a une opposition mais
il semble que la page de l'affrontement
électoral soit tournée et que l'on ouvre
peut-être la page d'une confrontation
parlementaire très bien alors pendant
tout le début de ce journal un certain
nombre de réactions sont tombés de
réaction syndicales Noël Mamère vous
allez nous les détailler oui pour Force
Ouvrière d'abord une constatation la
volonté du gouvernement de pratiquer une
large concertation avec les syndicats un
souci préserver la liberté de
négociation pour la CGT l'ouverture
sociale de raymondb c'est la
confirmation de la politique d'austérité
pour les travailleurs pour la
CFDT le gouvernement continue la
politique économique qui n'a pas résolu
les graves problèmes posés par la crise
pour la CFDT elle enregistré avec la
CFTC pardon elle enregistré avec
la place réservée à la politique sociale
quant à la CGC elle attend le détail de
l'application des mesures présentées par
Raymond bar et elle veut qu'elle soit
présentée sans tarder enfin pour les PME
elle relève que Monsieur bar le
reconnaît une spécificité mais regrette
le maintien de l'actuelle politique
d'austérité de du gouvernement bar voilà
pour ce débat qui aura fait oublier le
vote des députés hier soir qui ont
apprter approuvver pardon l'augmentation
des quotas de la France au FMI autrement
dit s'il faut schématiser le le budget
que les Français doivent consacrer au
Fond Monétaire International sachez
aussi que le groupe parlementaire RPR
réunit ce matin à affirmer son
indépendance par rapport au mouvement
gaulis dans son ensemble et puis qu'un
député socialiste monsieur Claude Évin a
demandé au Premier ministre d'autoriser
le retour en France de Daniel con bentit
au Conseil des ministres de ce matin le
chef de l'État avait bien sr évoquer ce
débat à l'Assemblée mais il a aussi
exprimé sa réprobation en tout cas la
réprobation du gouvernement français
devant ce qu'il a appelé l'exécution
indigne et barbare de Monsieur Aldo Moro
exécution at-il dit accompagné d'une
parodie de justice qui fait fi de tous
les droits de la personne humaine en
fait ce soir nul n'est sûr de la mort du
président de la démocratie chrétienne
les recherches sont poursuivies toute la
nuit et toute la matinée autour du lac
de la duchesse mais en vain on n'a pas
retrouvé comme l'avait annoncé les
briades rouges le corps de Monsieur
Morau alors comme ces terroristes se
livrent rarement à des opérations de
bluff bien on se pose ce soir des
questions et certains continuent à
s'accrocher à un fragile espoir
50 rotations d'hélicoptères 500
policiers carabiniers chasseurs alpin et
plongeurs sous-marins dans la confusion
la plus totale n'ont pu percer le
mystère aldomoro dans les montagnes des
abruses dès l'aube l'armée et la
gendarmerie ont fait sauter la glace qui
recouvre le lac de la duchesse les
hommes grrenouilles sont descendus dans
la couche d'eau mais aucun corps n'a pu
être localisé toute la journée ces
hommes ont tenté de rechercher le
moindre indice qui aurait pu les mettre
soit sur la piste de Monsieur aldomoro
soit sur celle des Brigades Rouges nous
sommes ici à 2000 m d'altitude et la
région est encore recouverte de 2 m de
neige le seul moyen d'accès est
l'hélicoptère ou 4 heur de marche à ski
et les enquêteurs imaginent mal les
brigade rougge transportant à dos
d'homme le corps de Monsieur aldoau dans
cette neige qui gêne considérablement
leur
travail tous les lacs de la région ont
également été fouillés ils sont nombreux
et très difficile d'accès eux
aussi les recherches pourraient être
suspendues jusqu'au dégel mais ni la
police ni l'armée ni la gendarmerie ne
veulent suspendre les recherches avant
d'être sûr que le corps de Monsieur Aldo
Morau ne se trouve pas dans la région
une hypothèse en eff fait reste possible
nous sommes ici à TR qu4 d'heure
exactement de la ville de Rome dans
cette région à peu près déserte des
abruses or les command des Brigades
Rouges ont très bien pu amener
rapidement ici Monsieur Aldo Morau dans
une cabane de bergers tout de suite
après l'enlèvement quelques jours après
l'exécuter puis le mettre dans le lac la
neige et le gel ensuite ont fait leur
œuvre c'est donc une hypothèse retenue
par les anquêteurs qui n'en écarte
aucune car jusqu'à présent les Brigades
Rouges ont toujours dit vrai de toute
façon que l'exécution soit ou non
confirmée le climat politique italien
est à l'Union nationale tous les partis
politiques se rendent bien compte que si
ce n'est pas le cas ils deviendront
davantage encore le jouet des briades
rouges Victor
van dans les milieu politique italien
tout se passe comme si Aldo Moro avait
été effectivement exécuté par les
Brigades Rouges tout le problème
actuellement consiste à limiter le plus
possible les conséquences que pourrait
avoir la disparition d'ALD Moro sur
l'opinion publ sur les institutions et
évidemment sur la démocratie chrétienne
les Brigades rouges dans leur message
ont dénoncé 20 ans de gouvernement
démocrate chrétien ils ont voulu frapper
très fort en enlevant Aldo Moro alors on
peut se demander si dans une certaine
mesure les Brigades rouges n'ont pas
réussi à affaiblir la démocratie
chrétienne mais je crois que le coupe
est certainement très grave aldomoro
représente les leaders contesté de toute
la démocratie chétienne mais je crois
aussi si on tient compte de ça que c'est
passe à la base et aussi au sommet qu'il
faut dire que la démocratie chrétienne a
réagi très bien elle est très consciante
de son rôle au centre du système
démocratique
italien le coupe est grave mais l'air
déjà
surmonté pas mal de difficultés dans ces
30 années est en condition de surmonter
et les institutions les institutions
italien institions fonctionnent le
Parlement est ouvert et enfin la vie de
l'État trouvé quelques difficulté pour
quelques jours mais maintenant tout est
je crois que enfin
elles sont en condition de gérer l'état
normalement on a remarqué une chose
c'est la position très ferme du Parti
Communiste Italien alors évidemment les
communistes vont dire que la situation
est exceptionnelle et qu'il faut
absolument former un gouvernement
d'union nationale en Italie il va y
avoir une nouvelle pression sur la
démocratie chrétienne est-ce que cette
fois vous n allez pas être obligé de
céder mais je ne crois pas qu'il
insisteront beaucoup sur cette thèse
enfin la situation est grave mais il se
rendent compte qu'il faut être réaliste
et garder avec beaucoup d'intelligence
au fond de la situation puis en France
je vous le disais le drame italien est
évoqué en conseil des ministres ce matin
et puis tout à l'heure à l'Assemblée où
les députés unanimes se sont associés au
message de sympathie du gouvernement
français par la bouche de Monsieur bar
voudrais- ici exprimer au gouvernement
et au peuple italien les sentiments
d'ind tion et de profonde sympathie
qu'inspire à la France le tragique
destin du président aldomoro et les
preuves que la démocratie subit dans ce
grand pays
ami dans ce manège infernal de la
violence et de la
conteviolence le problème n'est pas de
savoir qui a commencé mais bien qui
finira j'ai voulu dire cela devant vous
mes chers collègues et à travers vous
j'ai voulu le dire au
pays parce que pour ce qui les concerne
les socialistes qui n'ont pas composé et
ne composeront pas avec la violence
d'État ne composeront jamais avec le
terrorisme aucun débat de société et
vous savez que nous y tenons aucun débat
de société n'aurait de sens s'il ne
porait d'abord sur les valeurs qui
appartiennent à la longue conquête des
hommes sur euxmêmes et hors
desquels il n'y a
rien un mot encore sur ce dossier des
Brigades rouges qui sera le deè dossier
du journal Renato courcho qui est le
fondateur des briades rouges ne croit
pas à l'authenticité de ce message de ce
communiqué numéro 7 ça relance donc le
suspense quant au recherche sur le corps
de Monsieur aldomore oui ou non la
France a-t-elle fait exploser sa
première bombe à neutron je veux dire
que mes confrères sont très partagés
France Soir l'affirme mais le Monde
rapporte que cette information de
l'essai d'une bombe à neutron comparable
à celle des États-Unis que cette annonce
donc n'est pas prise au sérieux dans les
milieux informés en tout cas s'il y a eu
explosion cela s'est passé dans le plus
grand secret bien sûr et puis à titre
expérimental dans le
Pacifique si la bombe à neutron
française a vraiment été expérimenté
c'est ici à Mururoa dans les centres
d'essaiis du Pacifique mais selon les
spécialistes c'est loin d'être une bombe
opérationnelle comme le missile Pluton à
qui elle ressemblera dans l'avenir il
s'agirait plutôt d'un engin expérimental
probablement très volumineux quelle
conséquence tiré de cette possession
d'abord souvenez-vous que le président
américain Jimmy Carter vient de décider
que son pays fabriquera pas du moins
provisoirement une telle bombe puis
notons que Valérie giscardestin doit
présenter fin mai aux Nations Unies les
propositions françaises de désarmement
mondial alors cette fuite qui a permis
de confirmer la volonté de notre pays
annoncé plusieurs fois d'avoir des
armements nouveaux comme les missiles de
croisière par exemple ce que vous voyez
ici ou les bombes à neutron cette fuite
elle s'explique la France montre que le
cas échéant elle peut prendre en main la
défense de l'Europe si les Américains
reculent devant les Soviétiques c'est le
fameux droit min um à la sécurité
annoncé en janvier dernier par le
gouvernement français droit qui sera
d'ailleurs défendu à l'ONU car la bombe
à neutron n'est pas cette arme
terrifiante annoncée par les Soviétiques
eux qui détiennent des missiles
nucléaires capables de détruire
plusieurs centaines de fois toute la vie
sur Terre les Américains ont réussi à
diminuer la force d'explosion à diminuer
la retombée très fortement de sorte que
c'est devenu une arme à Rayonnement
renforce relativement mais il y a des
des armes tactiques beaucoup plus
sévères et beaucoup de gens en entendant
le mot arme à neutron que des
journalistes ont inventé ont de suite
cru que c'est une arme tout à fait
nouvelle et ont crié à
l'apocalypse la bombe à neutron a un
rayon d'action très faible de l'ordre du
kilomè au maximum elle tue les êtres
vivants et laisse intact les objets
inanimés c'est terrifiant certes mais
cela ne concerne que le champ de
bataille pas les civils de tout un pays
contrairement à ce qui se passe pour une
bombe atomique ordinaire un pays comme
le nôtre ne peut pas résister à une
attaque nucléaire massive avec des
bombes à neutron il peut au moins
défendre ses frontières si tous les
missiles mégatonique étent remplacé par
des bombes à neutrons la terreur
mondiale sur les populations civiles
diminuerait et ce serait un grand pas
vers le désarmement
mondial à ce stade du journal je
voudrais vous rappeler un rendez-vous
exceptionnel que vous avez sur cette
chaîne à 21h30 le premier document sur
le Cambodge filmé depuis 3 ans et demi
depuis donc l'entrée des mer Rouge dans
Pnom Pen ce document nous devons à l'un
de nos confrères yoslav niikolas
victorovic vous connaissiez le Cambodge
auparavant vous êtes allé souvent oui et
j'étais correspondant Chine alors j'ai
visitais fréquemment le Cambodge et donc
pour la première fois un journaliste
occidental a pu revenir depuis 3 ans et
demi qu'est-ce que vous avez découvert
alors un journaliste yugosl un
journaliste non aligné alors je rapporte
un document qui compare un peu le passé
mais qui parle plutôt de de
d'aujourd'hui de alors le présent par
rapport au passé c'est vraiment
impressionnant y a une telle différence
vra oui il a un T différence qu'est-ce
qui impressionne le plus c'est les
images de cette ville désertée par ses
habitants pas tellement on a on a déjà
que les villes sont désertées que les
villes sont évacuées mais les chantiers
qui sont pleins de de gens qui
travaillent là-bas que que le Cambodge
vit dans le chamb et au chantier et avec
une contrainte policière permanente non
j'ai pas vu j'ai pas pu remarquer de
beaucoup de des gens armés mais peu de
sourire oui un peu de sourire bien donc
donc rendez-vous à 21h30 pour ce
document le film sera accompagné de
témoignag que présentera Jean-Pierre
lecabach 21h30 les Israéliens se
retireront le 5 mai à 10 km de la
frontière au Sud Liban voilà ce qu' a pu
annoncer aujourd'hui court Vald à la
suite de conversation avec le chef
d'état-major de téaviv un premier
résultat positif donc de la visite du
secrétaire général de l'ONU au moment
même où Israël se donne un nouveau
président de la République il s'appelle
yitrak Navon il a été élu à l'unanimité
sans opposition c'est donc le 5e
président de l'État d'Israël depuis 30
ans à 57 ans Monsieur Navon ancien très
proche collaborateur de David bencoyon
et le premier juif d'origine sepharade
c'est-à-dire orientale à accéder à la
tête de l'État d'Israël il est là-bas
très populaire et très respecté dans son
PS confirmation de l'amélioration des
relations entre la France et l'Algérie
la visite qu'a entreprise Albain
Chalandon le président du groupe
pétrolier d'elfferap cette visite de 3
jours semble avoir été positif puisque
la société française pourrait reprendre
une activité de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée j'ai constaté à la suite de
ces entretiens et qu'il y avait une
volonté réciproque que Elf reprennent le
travail en Algérie avec la sonatrac cela
po se passer sous quelle forme et bien
euh diverses possibilités s'offr nous
les avons examiné il reste à choisir le
champ d'intervention d'Elf et les
modalités de gestion c'est ce qui sera
fait très vite dans les semaines les
mois qui viennent dans le cadre d'un
groupe de travail que nous avons décidé
de constituer pour déterminer dans
quelles conditions
peut revenir travailler en Algérie
pourez-vous reprendre une
participation à l'exploitation du du
pétrole
algérien je ne peux pas vous répondre
avec précision je dirais simplement que
la tendance serait peut-être de
s'orienter vers le gaz effectivement Elf
a une vocation gazière elle produit du
gaz elle en produira de plus en plus
elle en distribue en France d'autre part
nous savons que la consommation de gaz
en France va certainement se développer
beaucoup dans les années qui viennent
c'est peut-être par conséquent dans le
secteur du gaz que nous trouverons le
moyen de rétablir cette coopération
entre euh l'Algérie et Elf monsieur
Chalandon avait été reçu pendant plus
d'une heure par le Président bouédien je
faud dire que ici à la rédaction nous
avons été très sensibles par le très
nombreux courrier que vous nous avez
adressé à la suite de la diffusion de
notre portrait de sœur Emmanuel vous
vous souvenez cette religieuse française
qui s'occupe des dérités dans les
bidonville du cire j'ai même reçu d'une
main anonyme de Marseille ce matin un
chèque de 5000 francs nous n'avions pas
sollicit cette solidarité mais que tous
en soient remerciés début ce matin du 9e
congrès du Parti communiste espagnol
mais celui-ci a une originalité par
rapport au précédent c'est le premier à
s'être tenu dans la légalité depuis 46
ans 500 journalistes et vous dire qui
vont suivre avec intérêt l'évolution de
la contestation à l'encontre de Santiago
Cario tenant de
l'eurocommune les sport maintenant comme
prévu au soir des matchs allés des
quarts de finale Nancy au dépend de
Valencienne Monaco au dépend de Bastia
et Nice à ceux de Nant se sont qualifiés
pour les demi-finales de la Coupe de
France mais la surprise est venue de
Marseille où l'équipe locale a été
vaincue par socho et donc éliminé la
coupe une longue domination de
l'Olympique de Marseille qui ne donne
rien un arbitre Monsieur Martin qui ne
fait pas l'unanimité c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire et un contre de
l'équipe dominée qui obtient victoire et
qualification pour les demi-finales de
la Coupe de France so 79e minute ivzic à
Léon
Mayer un lob Baier et victorvinka arrive
trop tard après Saint-Étienne socho
l'outsider de la Coupe élimine
Marseille voilà j'ai deux dernières
nouvelles qui me parviennent à l'instant
je vous les donne elles sont toutes les
deux importantes d'abord selon le
ministère de l'Intérieur en Italie le
communiqué des briades rougge est
infondé les recherches effectuées
jusqu'à présent permettent donc de
conclure que finalement ce que
communiqué est faux ou en tout cas est
un communiqué qui visait à brouiller les
pistes et puis j'apprends qu'à Nice nous
avons appris donc l'arrestation d'un
complice des ravisseurs du baron hampin
voilà je vais vous donner comme chaque
soir chaque mercredi soir les résultats
du Loto si je les retrouve et voici donc
le 49 le 17 le 27 le 42 le 40 le 29 et
comme numéro complémentaire le 12 et
puis comme chaque soir le point sur la
mar noir les nappes sont toujours
menaçantes sur l'île de Saint et sur
doirenet les vents seront au sud-ouest
demain mais tourneront en principe
après-demain au nord-ouest ramenant donc
le mazout sur les côtes du finister nord
la météo pour le reste du pays demeure
médiocre une zone de nuage et de pluie
abordera cette nuit les régions de
l'ouest et atteindra dans la journée
l'est du pays ensuite et bien le temps
deveviendra variable avec des éclaircis
dans l'Ouest n'oubliez pas vos deux
derniers rendez-vous de la soirée 21h30
question de temps sur le Cambodge 22h30
2h35 Gard hols je souhaite à tous une
excellente soirée et j'espère avoir le
plaisir de vous retrouver
demain